desde el 2019 hemos visto cómo surgen
con mayor frecuencia estas protestas en
Irán pero tal vez ninguna había tenido
el alcance de la que estamos viendo en
este momento no solamente enterando
donde ayer cientos y cientos de personas
salieron a las calles en diferentes
puntos de la ciudad hasta bien entrada
la noche y se enfrentaban a las fuerzas
de seguridad que trataban de controlarlo
sino en muchas ciudades del resto del
país especialmente en el norte pero
cuentan quienes han participado
anteriormente en estas protestas y las
han analizado que la represión la
esperaban a un mayor cuando volviera al
país el presidente Ibrahim Rey sí que se
estaba Nueva York en la asamblea general
de las Naciones Unidas cuando llegó esta
mañana se reunió con algunos de los
integrantes o simpatizantes del gobierno
y dijo que había que controlar estas
protestas habló que estaban siendo
organizadas por los enemigos de Irán
Aunque reconoció que tenía la gente
había salido a protestar por la muerte
de maxa Mini esa joven de 22 años que
había sido capturada por la patrulla de
la moral la policía de la moral que
ahora estaba haciendo utilizada por los
enemigos de Irán Así que hoy se han
tomado medidas por ejemplo como cerrar
las universidades de Teherán los jóvenes
estudian a través de internet durante
toda la semana argumentan que hay dos
días festivos por la realidad es que
tratan de evitar estas protestas esta
mañana se reunían un grupo de ellos a
las afueras de la Universidad de Teherán
y eran reprimidos y muchos de ellos
captura